all right he said you said where are you
from originally Mexico
and how long have you been in the United
States 13 years 30 years tell me about
your chocolate you grew up with your
parents both parents Dan you started I
mean really you were bad at one point oh
yeah well it would eh did you become a
woman
one night when Megan might with my first
dressed like a woman was some 1980 1987
how do you family
the first Underwood well little by
little they look at me like a woman and
now it's okay everything okay
yeah so you go home and visit all the
time I'm dressing like a woman again I
wouldn't know
I'm not moment right now yeah Oh
pause woman start serious - yes oh
really
so where do you have that procedure done
the doctor the doctor does that for you
yeah yeah painful surgery a lot of pain
okay but you're happy I'm happy
yeah did you know as a child that this
was but you were this was here this was
you you were meant for this well you're
you're supposed to be a woman yeah it
was it difficult for you as a child
no with the other kids no yeah so here
we are for the morning and you're on the
street thinking of man right money
trying to make money do you make
that's Friday night I just got out only
two hours you offer two hours but not
all the time only two times or three
times a month
oh you got a job no just this justice
and the men and so you pick up men at
the end of their night up drinking and
party and getting high I don't drink no
but the men that pick you up
oh yeah they're they're drunk drunken
it's not in that easy for us yeah no I'm
sure they're violent sometimes some
can't you tell me a story I'm sure
you've had crazy things happen with him
one time one man take me a little far
away this the Syrian and and and he'd
take me you take me out of my clothes
and after that they don't want to do if
you don't want to give me my clothes of
two guys on the car for another for that
one in the trunk when we stay in the
place the guy could have furthered the
trunk to guys and take me the gloves oh
and they don't want to give me my
clothes and I walked all the way down
with no clothes on me over like one mile
why was that the past twenty jetsam of
yes dangerous very dangerous it's not
easy for us this did chap yeah
have you been in prison do the cops to
arrest you sometimes sometimes yeah
how many times have you been arrested
three it's just for day yes for a few
days the last time was enough I wake my
lesser race was on
to attach them in 110-mile officers
Network the cops leave you alone now so
your breasts are hormones or implants
expressed in Clinton they're big and
beautiful thank you
so when you visit your family you your
all your some women women all the time
all the time looking I'm looking at a
dressing like a woman you visit anywhere
at the stars and my house with my family
with my sister and you take hormones as
well okay
you